we're getting closer and closer to the
top of our list of the 30 story lines
for 2019 that we are paying the most
attention to and at number six the
audible thing in Green Bay
the tension between new coach Matt
Lafleur and specifically his offensive
system and the way that quarterback
Aaron Rodgers would like to run that
system and the battle lines are very
simple here the Matt Lafleur system
entails calling two plays in the huddle
and then when the quarterback comes to
the line of scrimmage and surveys the
defense the quarterback through the
application of parameters predetermined
by the coaching staff will decide which
of the two plays to use I mean it's not
a decision that the quarterback makes
based upon his preference it's based
upon what he sees across the line of
scrimmage that dictates which of the two
plays he calls and the offense moves
forward with that very limited
quarterback discretion well Aaron
Rodgers wants to have the freedom to do
whatever he sees fit at the line of
scrimmage and he has on multiple
occasions now most recently with our own
Chris Simms indicated that hey I've got
the experience and I've got the ability
to do things that others can't do why
don't you want to take full advantage of
that experience so that's where the
potential issue is it wasn't resolved
through the offseason program it needs
to be resolved before the start of the
regular season and I can tell you
spoiler alert how this is going to be
resolved rock-scissors-paper
and the ultimate rock in Green Bay is
Aaron Rodgers face of the franchise 32
million dollar per year contract and
what are they gonna do if he decides you
know what I understand what I'm supposed
to do but I'm gonna do what I want to do
what are they gonna do they're gonna
bench him for DeSean Kaiser we're gonna
do they're gonna give him a strong
talking-to they're gonna threaten him
they're gonna cut him they're gonna
trade him know he's the most powerful
member of the organization and he
ultimately is gonna be able to do
whatever he wants to do so that's how
this is gonna be resolved now the best
way to resolve it would be in a way that
allows Matt Lafleur to save face because
the players are now paying attention to
this you know some people like Sims
think it's good that this is all out in
the open and being discussed no I don't
think it's good for anybody because
you've got a locker room 52 guys other
than Aaron Rodgers who are watching this
tug of war between
the two most influential men in the
organization and how it plays out and
whether or not Rodgers wins or whether
or not Rodgers just decides I'm gonna do
whatever I want and he'll basically
launch a mutiny if need be one play at a
time ignoring what the pre-selected menu
of plays may be that they need to find a
way to let Rodgers do what he's gonna do
anyway and let Matt Lafleur basically
say hey it was his idea to do it that
way that's the best solution to this if
they can get there Rogers gets an
exception gets an exemption he gets a
pass as it relates to this offensive
system that would otherwise tie his
hands and Matt Lafleur needs to be the
one who stands up and says you know what
after carefully considering the
situation during the five weeks between
the offseason program and the start of
training camp I've decided that Aaron
Rodgers is going to have more freedom in
this offense because if Lafleur doesn't
do that that's gonna be the way it turns
out anyway
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports